jean philippe dugoin clément bonjour
merci de répondre à nos questions en
direct sur rt france vous dénoncez un
mensonge d'état sur le remboursement des
masques quelles sont les conséquences de
cette décision pour les collectivités
locales et les départements le rappel en
l'état prévoit de prendre en charge la
moitié du coût sur la base d'un plafond
fixé à 2 euros pour les masques
réutilisables bonjour oui effectivement
c'est quelque chose de profondément
choquant parce que c'est un décalage
entre la parole politique et la réalité
de ce qui est fait de l'action des
collectivités locales pour répondre une
situation de pénurie où les gens
n'avaient pas de masquer les services
publics n'avaient pas de masque eh bien
on s'est retroussé les manches
on a massivement acheté des masques que
ce soit la région de france 30 millions
de masques achetés par la région les
départements les agglomérations les
communes pour ma ville c'est 65000 euros
de masse qui ont été achetés et on n'a
pas attendu le 13 avril il discours du
président de la république pour
enclencher ses commandes
parce que si on avait attendu le 13
avril les masques qui sont en cours de
distribution aujourd'hui ceux qui ont
été donnés dans les ehpad dans les
hôpitaux à des policiers depuis des
semaines dont les attendrait toujours et
entre le discours qui a consisté à dire
il y aura pas de questions moyens on
viendra soutenir les collectivités qui
vont investir et la réalité où on
s'aperçoit qu'on met des règles d'accès
vous savez c'est le les toutes petites
lignes en bas du contrat
eh bien on se rend compte que dé facto
toutes les collectivités locales qui ont
agi qui ont investi et bien se
retrouvent lésés et que celles qui vont
être aidés à la limite c'est celle qui
vont acheter des masques qui ne
serviront à rien entre guillemets parce
que ce qui est commandé aujourd'hui ça
va arriver fin mai en juin voire
peut-être eux-mêmes en juillet à un
moment où il y aura plus et nury de
masques c'est dire qu'on offrira des
goodies on offrira des cadeaux mais on
offrira plus quelque chose qui va
répondre à un besoin vital de répondre à
une urgence
donc moi aujourd'hui comme beaucoup de
maires qui ont écrit au chef de l'état
comme beaucoup de parlementaires de
toutes tendances politiques confondues y
compris des élus de la majorité
je demande tout simplement que la parole
politique et encore du poids de la
valeur dans ce pays et que président de
la république a ri
faire que son administration et son
gouvernement applique la parole
politique et quelles sont les démarches
que vous comptez mettre en place vous
hais les élus qui vous suivent alors on
est nombreux à voir écrit directement
emmanuel macron à l'elysée pour ma part
ce samedi dernier où on est aujourd'hui
de nombreux maires à l'avoir fait
beaucoup de parlementaires l'ont fait
certains parlementaires ont posé des
questions écrites des questions orales
et j'espère tout simplement que le bon
sens va revenir envisager des actions en
justice
non parce que ça n'aurait pas de sens on
est si vous voulez sur quelque chose qui
pour moi est une question de morale est
une question de justice est une question
de vérité de la parole entamé des moyens
en justice à l'échelle est une
collectivité comme la mienne j'ai 65000
euros d'achat de masquer la question
elle est celle de la haute du
pourcentage éventuelle de remboursement
j'aurais pas intérêt après il ya des
collectivités qui pourrait il y avoir
intérêt de la région ile-de-france avec
valérie pécresse c'est 30 millions de
masques ont été commandés 30 millions
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on peut ré
ouvrir les transports si on ne les avait
pas commandé avant le 13 avril les
transports ne fonctionnerait pas
aujourd'hui où une serait pas en
situation pouvoir contribuer à une
reprise et une relance économique de
manière relativement secure donc voilà
c'est vraiment une question de justice
et de poids de la parole politique et
c'est quelque chose qui est pour moi
profondément choquant ce que vous savez
de plus en plus de 2 français de
citoyens ne croient plus aux politiques
ne croient plus en la puissance publique
ne croit pas en l'exercice des mandats
publics parce que il ya toujours ce
décalage entre la parole et les actes
voilà qu'est ce qu'on y pense que vous
rêve c'est grey et qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui arguaient que votre
anticipation est peut-être trop hâtive
qu'il fallait attendre le feu vers l'iss
devrait m'aider mais c'est trop hâtive
donc il aurait fallu qu'on ne distribue
pas dans les étables il y avait des
morts il aurait fallu qu'on ne donne pas
aux policiers qui n'étaient pas couverts
il aurait fallu qu'on distribue pas dans
les pharmacies il aurait fallu qu'on ne
donne pas aux services publics
municipaux pour qu'ils puissent
continuer à travailler
il aurait fallu près reaper n'en ai pas
et qu on ne ramasse plus les ordures
ménagères
bien on aurait pu effectivement laissé
les gens complètement démunis chose qui
s'est retrouvée qui se serait retrouvé
en situation si les collectivités
n'avaient pas agi les millions de
masques qui ont été apportées par les
régions les départements les communes
si on les avait pas mis dans le circuit
je sais pas comment les choses auraient
tenu jusqu'au déconfinement et tout ce
qui est en train d'être distribués
aujourd'hui trop bien en avoir
conscience c'est des commandes qui ont
été faites avant 13 avril
avants 13 avril et puis si on veut
rentrer dans le détail de cette
circulaire parce qu'on est
je disais vous disiez mensonge d'état
mais c'est aussi une mesquinerie d'état
parce qu'on met des conditions qui font
la parole du premier ministre a été de
dire on remboursera la moitié de la
valeur des masques la réalité c'est que
c'est entre le quart et le tiers qui
sont remboursés ce qu'on a mis un
plafond à 50 % d'un montant de 2 euros
hors taxes pour un masque réutilisables
aujourd'hui c'est des masques qui sur le
marché vont trouver pas à moins de deux
euros 55 60 hors taxes et qui peuvent
monter jusqu'à 3 euros 3 euros 54 euros
pour être libre et vite
donc la réalité c'est que le soutien qui
a été affichée à 50%
en réalité les de 25 ou 30% voilà j'ai
justement dernière
dernière question pardonnez moi de vous
couper il nous reste plus beaucoup de
temps voilà beaucoup des masques on
parle beaucoup des tests qu'ont fait
beaucoup polémique ces deux derniers
mois et y lire les soignants de
l'hôpital robert debré ont manifesté
pour demander plus de moyens alors
qu'emmanuel mâcon vient de donner le
coup d'envoi pour son plan hôpital qui
devrait démarrer je cite dans les
prochaines semaines votre réaction
je comprends que l'hôpital français soit
à bout c'était déjà le cas avant cette
crise là ça a mis la crise ducobu d'amis
en avant a mis en lumière les manques de
moyens structurels de l'hôpital mais là
encore il y a une parole présidentielle
j'espère qu'elle sera suivie d'effet et
le problème dans ce pays ça fait des
années des années on a des décalage
entre les annonces entre la parole et
les actes et je crois qu'aujourd'hui les
hospitaliers comme l'ensemble des
français ne peuvent plus accepter ça et
on peut comprendre chacun peut accepter
qu'ils aient des choses qui ne sont pas
faisable mais dans ce cas là faut le
dire faut pas faire des effets d'annoncé
quand on n'est pas capable de tenir
le président macron a fait des annonces
fortes par rapport à l'hôpital comme ça
a été fait d'ailleurs sur le tourisme il
hier par edouard philippe
il faut que ce soit tenue merci c'est
faire d amour pour qu'elles ne soient
pas tenues c'est grave merci merci jean
philippe dugoin clément d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes à vice-président de la région
ile-de-france est maire de mennecy mère
unis